hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are back at the first
American chess congress but this is not
a part of the the tournament game it's
lupus and versus Paul Charles Murphy
Paulson defeated his opponent three to
zero Murphy also defeated his opponent
three to zero we have seen all three
games and now before waiting for the
second part of the tournament where
Paulson will meet among Montgomery and
Murphy will meet judge meet they decided
to play a blindfold the game it's
basically a part of Paulson's loophole
since the simultaneous exhibition he
announced that he will play four
opponents simultaneously blindfolded
which in those days was considered just
incredible no one ever attempted more
than playing more than four people in a
blindfold contest so Murphy accepted at
the invitation but he said only if he
plays blindfold as well
otherwise if more if more fee just
accepted to play against the apples and
we're only possible blindfolded then if
more of you wins he didn't really win
anything and if he loses it would be it
will be quite shameful so this is the
game I do hope you enjoy it let's check
it out Paulsen opens with a four we have
E 5 that Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and
now Knight to c3 I'm going for the three
nights opening and Bishop to c5 by
Murphy of course both players going for
very rapid development with Bishop to b5
now attacking the knight here with the
idea of maybe winning the pawn these six
so the d5 pawn is nicely defended and
now d4 as the knight on c6 is pinned so
he captures on d4 by Murphy Knight
captures on d4 n now Bishop to d7
unpinning the night we have Knight
captures and c6 and now B captures and
c6 pushing Paul sends Bishop back push
it back to a for now c4 d3 or e 2 are
all excellent squares however for some
reason Paulsen decides to bring the
bishop back to a4 but okay
Queen to f6 already morph is threatening
mate here also just castles here but
it's interesting to note that this
position after this game has never been
reached again so as a move
we have a game that was never repeated
so castles of course this defends
against in any checkmate threats and
unlike the East seven more freaking
dangerous development and now Paulsen
should definitely consider a move like
Bishop to b3 the bishop will be much
better here on this agonal or even the
shots the b2 continuing with Queenie to
maybe bring the rook over to e1 taking
each one f4 all very nice moves
however he goes for Bishop to e3 and
this you know critics have been
criticizing polls and for this move
since since he played it but in those
days of course you know the oppositional
chess wasn't really a thing well maybe
maybe with Paulson and morphe it was but
here in a blindfold game Paulson decided
that it was okay to mess up his pawn
structure to get to the semi open file
for the rook although it would be much
better if this bishop was here then
maybe Bishop to e3
if the bishop retreated the c-4 then
maybe this idea would be okay since then
you would already have the f7 pawn under
attack but here morphe just captures it
Bishop captures on e3 f captures on e3
opens up an attack - morphix Queen and
now Queen h6 morphe just goes after the
e3 pawn we have Queen to b3 defending
but now with the points being doubled
like this there's really nothing to
challenge more fees night when it lands
on e5 so Knight to g6 and the knight is
now coming to e5 you do not have the f1
or the deep one to kick it away from
there rook 81 Paulsen also continues
with rapid development 95 just putting
night - a nice nice central square Queen
back to E - and now more feet just
castles we have h3 taking away the g4
Square for more fees pieces in our King
h8 preparing to bring the rook over to
g8 we have Knight to d1
now adding another defender here but
also preparing Tori maneuver the knight
via Knight to f2 also Knights to D 3 and
here Murphy finds well a really
inspirational g5 and Howard Howard
Stanton some years after this game was
played said something about this move
but we're gonna get to that after we
check out the game so g5 he wants to
play g4 bust open the position also you
the orgy fall for his rook so let's see
what happens we have Knights the f2 now
kind of good controlling g4 although not
really if more if he wanted to he could
push it but first more feet prepares it
rook the g8 we have Knights the d3 also
instead of 93 maybe g4 and that's not a
g4 maybe instead of 9th to d3 g4 to
prevent black from pushing g4 however
then Queen to h4 is very strong and now
Queen g3 check is coming followed by
Knight to f3 so you'd have to place not
like King G - but then h5 you again will
be successful in busting open at the
King's defenses so after rook to g8
Paulson decides to go for night to d3
and here more if he just continues with
g4 and ok Knight captures an e5 by poles
and D captures on e5 and now H captures
and g5 Bishop captures and g5 by Murphy
and now Queen to f2 so here morph
responds are somewhat hanging this is
hanging this is hanging then this might
be hanging but morphe doesn't really
care about that or all morphe cares
about is that Paulsen doesn't play queen
g6 and trades Queens so look the g6
preventing that and now Queen captures
on f7 by Paulsen and here morphe just
brings the bishop back to e6 Bishop to
e6 attacks the Queen and also frees the
G square for the rook so what do you
play here it's a really a bad position
for white whatever you play will not be
sufficient so pause and decided to grab
a point here Queen captures on c7
which might have Queen captures on e5
with check next but it was in this
position and moved 23 that Paul Morphy
announced a checkmate in five and after
thinking about the position for for some
time we Paulson resigned the game in
this position without playing any any
more moves so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this announced the
mate in five left that morphe announced
while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations
just just a note it took morphine and
pulse in six hours to finish this game
they played from a 4:30 p.m. till 10:30
p.m. and then at 10:30 p.m. morphe
announced the meet in five so really for
those of you who found it
congratulations and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
it's rook captures and g2 and now with
best defense white is getting made it in
five so you have to capture the rook
pink actress and now you have two
options so you either go Queen h3 or
look the g8 Czech Queen h3 is not as
nice as rook 2 g8 maybe because after
King g1 it's right away
rook to gee it sure King f2 or you could
give up the Queen which will again
justify the mate in 5 with best defense
but you could just move the king king of
to a now look to g2 the does the job
just the same however after the screen
captures on g2 you could also go for
rook to g8 check but and then it's a
much nicer mate king of 3 Queen to h5
check not allowing the king to escape
King F - Quinta h2 with Czech king of
three and now the bishop delivers mate
with Bishop to g4 so this is a well more
if he had in mind when Paulsen played
Queen captures on c7 and of course was
install this blindfold and then he just
resigned the game so really a brilliant
game by morphine Paulsen really gave him
too much bye-bye playing the Bishop to
e3 move after that more fee just you
know crash down on the position and he
was unstoppable and I mentioned that
Howard Stanton mentioned something about
this game so here it is from David
Lawson's book Howard Stanton made a
generous comment on Murphy's manner of
play when he later published in his
chest column in The Illustrated London
News of February 1st 1862 so 5 years
after this game was played the first
blindfold game more if he played with
paulsen he says in the Faculty of
imparting vitality to a position mr.
Murphy's hardly second to Laborde own a
very famous French player it is very
rare indeed to find the game of his
which is not
in some part in livened by a stroke of
vigor or a flash of inspiration the
advance of the pawn here morphism of 16
operates a change in the aspect of
affairs which is almost magical so this
is a house tartan considered at this
game and especially morph is move 16 if
you don't remember after 91 morph is g5
this is the move Stanton's talking about
and it really is a it really is an
impressive idea I mean kind of weakening
your position but not really as morphe
more Fischer start Paulson couldn't
really do anything about it but yeah out
of the for blindfold games in a
simultaneous exhibition that Paulson
played he only lost the one to Murphy he
drew one and one two so all in all he
won his blindfold exhibition match with
two wins one draw and one loss but which
is to be expected if you have a more fee
as your opponent so yeah that's that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it
like I said six hours not bad for a
blindfold game and we are continuing
with the Paul Morphy saga here we are
going into the next games of the
American chess congress where a person
meets Montgomery and Murphy meets George
meek so we'll see what happens and we'll
the two of them meet again
sure once again I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Pollock [ __ ] Yan
par Varun vara Darian dog McNab and
Frank combs for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon like I
said continuing the Morphy saga checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day